and now Faulk trying to skate away from the Jets
for checking here's Krug ahead Capp it in going
wide shoots it on goal and it's save by hu and
then Kyle conter number 81 there he lost it Thomas
R shouldered off the puck by morisy and now Josh
morrisy trying to work it away Blues trying to
hunt it back they do here's Kyu out with it and
he looks around coming off a three-point effort
give St to the nine of Hearts a drive on goal
and a save by helot and then Veron trying to
Center one that's off of shin had ver gets it
again makes a move around for fet on goal and
a save by heluk now Dylan deelo ahead for Lowry
hit by sunquist Jets the pass in front morrisy
with it shoots it right on goal and a good save
by benon now for the sweet David Guston in on
the wing and a shot right on goal and a save by
Bennington on kupari Thomas for B davic back to
crew that shot tip rebound B davit had a wide
open goal it was blocked by Dello see the shot
on net the deflection huk with the save pav bunich
pouncing on the puck and right there the puck was
off the Stick of Dello The defenseman's Crawling
over we get a good look at the plazatire goalie
cam from above in the league at 69% now they
get the P Center I and Morgan Baron he walks
down the wall shoots it on goal and a pad save
by benon 35 to go in the power play C in finds F
and then Hayes a drrive right on goal and a save
by Hayes the former Jet and a save by Helu who
entered cleanly Here Comes sod pass in front for
Hayes he dust It Off back to faul he waits gets
it back again faul shoots it tip just wide Maybe
by sod fighting to the checking of Schmid right
in front and a shot on goal by S didn't get a lawn
on it and it's saved by hellu now it is shle again
back for morisy and then Connor Ducks it off
and Connor gets it again watched by Ley down
to the goal line in front and trle scores what a
play and a power play goal and it's one- nothing
Winnipeg well Winnipeg Jets do a great job of
moving that puck around quickly passes tape to
tape they work it around here they get it down
low and shily kind of gets lost in traffic and
sneaks in back door Robert Thomas just getting
there a hair too late on this one here in fact
getting a piece of it with the heel of his stick
there but winipeg moving around really quick and
then eers who can really skate he'll rip it around
Hulk there now Peretti number 91 gets it at the
line Dylan a drive rebound attempt another shot on
goal another shot by eers and Bennington got over
they got to try and forget about that goal and go
back to work as neighbors goes wide shoots it on
goal to sa by halot Jason Appleton out of Michigan
State at the line good stick there by Paro kept in
though Connor for shle to Connor shoots it
right on goal and a save by Bennington and
Bennington wanders leades it for Paro on to this
side for Kyu and again the Jets force a turn over
here's Pon right in he scores Neil pan into the
top corner and the Jets lead to [Music] nothing
well we've been highlighting morisy here for most
of the game as a guy that jumps up into the play
Blue's looking to get out of Their Own
Zone doesn't happen makes pan available
on the weak side comes down the wall and puts it
blocker side here Jordan Bennington sliding over
possibly giving up just a little too much on
the blocker side see quite a bit of net over
there Pon sees it too as Thomas comes in
happening in the slot couple of jets are
there with sticks Tucker the line that's off the
board now kaen battles there here's Thomas with
it fires it he scores Robert Thomas goals in
four straight a new career high and it's two
to [Applause] one the bles do a good job on the
four check here pounding the pucks Robert Thomas
great Edge work on that one too just turns on
a dime and doesn't hesitate I think that's the
best thing about this is right here the edor
gets his head up quickly and then that little
drag as Conor sets it up for Fetti on the half
courts the first to Connor now morrisy and then
I have follow back to morrisy Conor the onetime
and he scores that was tipped and it gets by
Bennington and the Jets are two for two on
the power play as they move it around Kyle
Conor makes himself available on half wall and
then right here drops the one timer looks like
it may have changed directions looks like kind
of fool Jordan Bennington right there off Nick
lety stick and then off the post and in Kyle Conor
pulling the trigger right here and you can see it
right there hits Nick lety stick changes direction
as we approach the Midway point of the second in
front the Kyo to lety wide open and that was
blocked again by a defenseman that was close
Nick ly have been robbed here tonight this one
just happened Nick lety getting the puck back
door and Nestico now Robert Thomas there Jet
Center shley right on and a save by Bennington
what a chance there for shley oh right top of
the blue paint look at tracking the puck right
here and then gets a nice little push out glove
up high now morrisy shoots it up high and off
the glass kept in by Dello and then twisted
around by AA follow look out Bennington back
to the goal they score and Kyle Connor with
Bennington out of the net makes it [Music]
41 here on the replay Bennington down there
and then I just don't think he saw the wiip
jet forward I don't think Bennington knew that
shley was going to be right there it goes off
the shley skate bounces out front Conor makes no
mistake in front pton had to get back quickly but
that was tipped toward the goal now Shen up the
middle has some speed here Shen down the wing a
shot and he scores Shen makes it a 4-2 [Music]
[Applause] game well this is why you put pucks
on the net is a nice clean break up for the blues
Tory k up to Braden Shen enters over the blue line
and then fires a shot but one thing you got to
look at here's Brandon sad going to the front
of the net here that creates a certain amount
of chaos for the goalie because he's thinking
to himself I can't let a rebound just drop cuz
there's another player here and sometimes they
lose focus comes a head bre at the point can't
hold it in and now shley gets around the blues
defense and a shot and a save by Bennington how
did he get that shot away still 42 Jets late
third and a good keeping now it's off a leg and
Appleton in a race for it and he's in the Clare
Appleton and a right pad save by Bennington to
keep the Blues in it then K trying to keep it
in with cap and they do that Shin in the slot
couple of jets are there and finally poked away
for fetty at the empty net and he scores and Co
per Fetti with the empty net or his second of
the year and it's 52 you see here it's a it's
a little sloppy a little gritty there and then
Peretti gets it so the blues two game winning
streak will come to an end as the Jets come
in and win it five to the final as they wrap
up their three-game road trip with two wins